will you ever return to the bachelorette
i mean
i think that's like truthfully the
million dollar question but i have to
say at least that that time for me
really served me so
it's taken up a lot of
me time for the last four years that i'm
ready to just
do the next thing take a break for a
minute yeah it's not a no but a pause
it's a pause
i i love it well we've talked all about
dating do you want to do a quick game of
um the drews and don'ts of dating we're
calling it
i thought you'd never ask okay great
this is the truth of dating
all right first up someone researching
someone on instagram before going on a
date drew or don't
that's a drew
oh i mean just a little bit oh no
because i do too oh i actually was
relieved that was like oh good so i'm
not wrong i'm trying to figure out who
someone is i'm a little nervous i'm a
woman i feel vulnerable i just want to
know you know
are you a
serial killer safe person yeah
yes thank you i got you i guess are you
crazy no it's true
okay dating someone 10 years younger
drew or don't it don't
is that bad no i'm totally with you i
don't want to change someone's diapers i
mean honey
i'm sorry you're 10 years younger do you
know what a
[ __ ] i was 10 years ago i i wouldn't
want to date me that's what i'm trying
to say 10 years ago absolutely not oh
god you learned so much
you have a lot of life to live okay so
yes okay bringing up an ex on the first
date
that's a dome me too that's a dog
i'm like leave that ghost in laundry
elsewhere
okay
dressing to the nines on a first date
drew or don't that's a true i'm totally
gay too
i mean don't you feel so good when you
feel good about yourself that's when i'm
most confident well um okay so you get
ready for a date i totally agree i love
any excuse to dress up um you have
partnered up with the skin care brand
number seven and we've actually teamed
up today with them as well will you tell
me about this partnership number seven
is all the rage people are so loyal to
your brand i read every single
post and magazine and i'm a total beauty
junkie
and tell me about working with number
seven because they're amazing okay first
of all now i'm kind of jealous because i
thought i was bringing the like uk's
best kept skincare secret to you because
it actually is because this brand
okay so it actually happened pretty
organically so i packed obviously to go
to london for about two and a half weeks
and i was gonna be that girl this trip i
was gonna unpack everything the second i
got there uh-huh yeah you're making that
face cause like we don't we always say
we're gonna do it and then we don't do
it yeah totally so i unpacked everything
and i started getting ready for the day
um and i realized i didn't bring my
moisturizer or my sunscreen
so i was like okay cool now i'm gonna go
look for something so i went to the
convenience store there's boots out
there so i went into my boots
and i was like okay
this is the thing i don't want to spend
so much money on a product because i
forgot it at home i want something
that's good that i'm gonna be able to
travel with and accessible exactly and i
was looking around and i saw like this
big display and it said like number
seven and there was actually a
consultant there and i was like i feel
like i've seen your brand before i don't
know much about it tell me about it i
need a moisturizer and sunscreen
and then she goes off and she was
extremely passionate about this company
and she was going off about like the
science behind it all and and and
the corrections that it makes to your
skin
and i was like sign me up i'm in i ended
up getting the lift illuminate and i've
been using it every single day since
i've gotten back since i was in london
so what is your very favorite product
okay it's number seven lift and luminate
day cream and i love it because number
one it hydrates better than moisturizers
that cost 10 times more in the market
and we all know sometimes when it costs
more that doesn't mean it's works better
no it doesn't no and guess what what 40
off at walgreens right now
right now
i'm so excited because talking about
this only leads me to telling you that
everyone in our studio audience is
actually going home with a selection of
number seven products today
[Music]
you